[Music]
special offers everywhere but not a
customer in sight a problem in shopping
zones across Germany even when it's not
so cold today it's minus 10 degrees
Celsius in the small Bavarian town of
Greensburg you have to be pretty
desperate to venture outside at all
hello I need a ski helmet right follow
me I'll show you what we've got
I plan to set off on my trip next week
I'm already thinking a skiing holiday is
bound to be expensive manga yacht fall
Oh
so it's our Pina mega JV I want to check
how much the competition's charging what
does it cost here special offer at one
hundred and twenty nine euros right now
2900 1906 if you want to check things
out on the internet there's never any
guarantee that you'll get the right size
here you'll find just the right size and
you'll even get advice thrown in for
free as well but if I order it online I
can get it delivered and send it back if
I want that's no problem here either
just go to our website you'll get the
helmet there and if you order by 4:30
we'll even deliver it today for six
months the view in Ginsberg de websites
fifty retailers have been offering
thousands of articles
nikola tesla the website is this
Ginsberg's answer to amazon honestly no
one stands a chance against amazon the
website is really only there to give us
an online presence our customers come
from all over germany laughs our orders
come from grinsberg
the other half from around the country
[Music]
but can that hope to drop in sales
caused by sites like Amazon in a
bookshop which also offers school
supplies like satchels I learn another
shopping trick what happens if someone
photographs a barcode yes nowadays
you've got software which automatically
shows the product on the internet so you
get customers who walk into your shop
look for something then just take a
picture of it if they like it it's quite
cheeky yeah but that's just the way
things are when retailer in Gunzburg
said a woman tried on 10 pairs of pants
in his shop photographed the ones she
wanted and then said she'd order them
online Internet that's why Hermann Hutta
has been online for years where he
markets the hundreds of thousands of
articles in his store room he says
people are going into town less and that
has repercussions 70% of all sales are
made on impulse so if I don't go to town
to buy that coat I also don't have the
chance to snap up a book on the other
hand customers actually going into a
shop a better informed than ever before
thanks to the internet that's good for
retailers people who come into this wine
shop ask for specific wines try them and
then get them delivered to their homes I
only sell Italian wines but I still have
800 different types from every region
north to south and the islands you'll
find reds whites roses and bubbly here
in relatively small goons burg I can
offer you a selection you'd normally
only find in big cities but that's only
pasta
because I combine brick-and-mortar
retail with online retail without the
online operation behind me I couldn't
maintain such a wide range or offer such
good prices what is that cost nine euros
80 and if I want to order it in Berlin
where I live what would I pay then
absolutely no problem it'd be the same
price you order it on via and goons berg
de and we'll ship it anywhere in Germany
for free paradoxically the otherwise
disruptive internet offers some
conventional retailers at least a much
better chance of survival